And this is very similar to how D3 does its joins.
In the case of two tables, let's think of Table one as our data file,
in this case data.tsv, where every row is a row in our file.
And Table two here for the department are all the HTML and
SVG elements on our webpage.
And when we perform that magical data join, we simply associate every row
in our data file with the corresponding element on our web page.
In the case of our scatter plot, we're adding circles,
based on some common key, that associates the two elements.
The question actually arises,
what happens to rows in the tables that either don't have a match or
elements on our webpage that don't have corresponding data to bind to?
Well, that is exactly what the special selection .enter that
follows the data bindings for.
And before moving on, just to make this example a tiny bit more concrete,
in D3 there's the idea of a key that maps data to elements.
As long as the data has the same key, in this case the department ID,
as to an HTML element that has previously been bound, they'll map to the same.
Let's say, for example, on the first time through our code,
we have an empty selection for the circle elements before the data bind.
When we bind our data to the empty selection,
think of it as creating something of an imaginary placeholder.
That has the value of our data, so in this case, for every row in our data
table it will actually create an adjacent second department table.
The .enter selection corresponds to all of these elements.
In this new mirror table that the databind creates.
Which then get appended to whatever we first selected, in this case,
the SVG element.
So on the first time through, there's no circles on the page, we bind data,
select all the bound data through placeholder circles that are not yet
on our page, which there won't be any, and then for
every one of those, we append a circle to our SVG element.
Now if we wanted to re-run this code, without changing data, or
without changing our selections, nothing will happen.
The reason being is that since the data never changed,
the key of the bond data never changed.
So our enter selection which corresponding to all the new elements to
draw on the page will simply be empty.
So we dont append anything new.
In theory, we could run this line of code 100 times and
our chart won't change, as long as our data and our selections don't change.
And again this is one of the strengths of the declarative syntax and
allows us to build complex animations where only some elements of our data or
some elements of our web page actually change from one frame to the next